I was watching this ad on TV for
Colonial Williamsburg has anybody been
there have you been there yeah it's a
recreation rig of a 19th 18th 19th
century town yes yeah and the the ad on
TV for it's like Colonial Williamsburg
you're gonna have a fun event
and so now it is not yeah
not their slogan and it just shows like
a bunch of old-timey Ben Franklin dudes
churning butter like bring your kids
it's boring again you're incorrect
and I was watching the ad for it and for
some reason the black part of my mind
took over and I turned into Chuck D from
Public Enemy and I got all militant and
I was like man that's messed up man
it's not a lot of diversity in Colonial
Williamsburg brah we're all my black
brothers and sisters getting their
reenactment on and then I was like oh
yeah black people weren't having a good
time they probably wanted to glaze over
that part of history for the 30-second
commercial yeah so I thought how funny
would it be in me and my friend Jermaine
we both dressed up like slaves with like
shackles around our necks and tattered
robes and actually went down and crashed
a Civil War Reenactment I've messed with
all the Torres so actually I brought it
so what were you yelling as you ran
through like I bought a clip you have a
clip these people have no idea that this
is gonna no idea what's going
look at this clip of your you crashing a
Civil War reenactment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what Abraham Lincoln was there and did
nothing to take care of love